How difficult is it to return
a pro tennis serve?
We invited the hardest
tennis server in Finland
to join us
and challenged strangers
to return our serves
Oh, here we go!
If they manage to complete
all the levels
they win €1,000!
Thanks to Skillshare
for sponsoring this video!
First level, my serve!
It's in!
That's €10!
85 kilometers an hour
Pretty good!
Next, we have to break the hundred!
Are you going to go all the way?
Of course!
Thanks!
What's your tennis background?
Top 10 in Finland
Oh, OK!
I go
ALL IN!
He is one of the best
servers in Finland
So, I mean
it will be a nice challenge for me!
Never felt that much pressure
with such a bad serve!
Sorry!
Make sure to subscribe and help us out!
He's under pressure
He will have pressure!
Not me!
Ooohhhh!
It's out!
Let's check it!
Yeah!
Oh, sorry, Boris!
It was a good try!
So, Arttu, are you ready?
Just woke up and everything is fine!
Are you going to go all the way?
Yeah, of course
I'm here for the €1000!
Of course!
Oh, is it in?
That's in!
Ready?
Oh!
It wasn't even close!
Spin really has a difference
Still waiting!
It's going to be a boring day I guess
Can I make the first serve?
Be gentle!
Unfortunately, I sprained my ankle
I can do a serve
I think!
Oh!
76 KPH!
Without the ankle brace
it would have been 176 KPH!
You choose to continue?
I'm going all the way!
Wow!
Oh no!
I'm little bit getting cold
I mean it's been half an hour!
Do you think you'll make it
to the final level?
I don't know!
I'm pretty nervous!
So, for level one
You get to choose
whoever of us serves to you
Let's say you!
You can serve! OK, thank you!
He's got the crutches!
That was a wrong decision!
I'm just bluffing all the time!
Oh, she's getting ready
to return the serve like a pro!
Oh!
That was a good side spin, under spin
but she got it!
Too slow maybe!
Yeah!
She's a pro!
Do you want to take the main challenge?
I'm going to take the main challenge!
OK, that's good
That's good!
While we wait for the final level
Let's talk about Skillshare
Who was kind to sponsor
and make this video possible
Skillshare is a creative
learning platform
with thousands of online classes
in a wide range of topics
such as film and video
illustration
photography
and productivity!
If you have a specific skill
that you're trying to learn
Skillshare is a great place
to get started!
Recently I took the Skillshare class
Learn Adobe After Effects for Beginners
by Jordy Vandeput
with the idea
to learn make some cool special effects!
€1000 on the line!
It's all about luck now
I go big wide!
I honestly
didn't even see that it was in
because it was so fast!
With the help of a Skillshare class
I was able to make this pretty cool edit
in just a few hours!
The classes are great way
to get inspired to learn new skills!
As a special offer
that sign up
using our link in the description
So you can start exploring
your creativity today!
Thank you Skillshare!
Unless somebody receives Otto's serve
He gets €1,000
So make sure to watch until the end!
We have our next challengers!
Real professionals!
Is he the guy who's going to serve?
Oh, OK!
No problem!
We've seen him
many times on television
We know what to do!
We know the guy!
I think I just try to block!
Nice!
Bam, bam, bam, bam!
Oh, nice!
So €333 I've earned!
I see! Clever!
Nice!
That's the way to do it!
Otto, let's bring it on!
He looks like a like a tourist
A beginner!
€1000 prize!
All right!
What are you going to do with it?
My wife is going to take care of that
I don't have to decide!
Ready!
Oh!
I didn't see that you served!
You didn't serve that one!
197 kilometers per hour!
Oh, I should have got that!
So what would you do
if you receive Otto's serve?
I have to buy new tennis shoes
If he gets it
he should buy more of those
And he got it!
It's time to change the outfit!
What's your tennis background?
I've been playing my whole life
OK, OK!
He's not fooling around anymore!
And it's in!
C'mon!
Time to change the outfit again!
He's got a shirt that says tennis on it!
Was it in?
Yeah, it was in!
Another one! Very good!
She's excited!
She's already going!
I think you're standing a bit too far
My serves are going to be quite soft
If I get it on court
That's another small victory for me
Oh, wait!
Oh!
Did I? It was in?
I got my first serve!
Thank you!
86 kilometers per hour!
Congrats for the first serve!
Thank you!
This is a great achievement
So we're going to switch up
Otto's lefty serve is going to be level one!
I feel a bit humiliated but OK!
But you can humiliate him!
No, but that's a given
You know, he can
He can use his stronger hand too!
This is looking impressive!
I have to write down these moves!
And he's going to get it?
Oh! He got it! He plays it safe
I need to warm up again!
I'm going to serve
with the left hand also
OK!
Oh!
That was in!
That serve was in!
Appreciate it!
He's trying to get into my head
But I'm going to ace him!
You see, he's nervous
He's nervous!
You hit it!
That was in!
It wasn't an ace this time
Yeah, it wasn't an ace
Still a really good serve!
Do you have a tennis background?
I played a little bit!
I'm more of a geek!
I'm shaking!
Very easy! Nice!
C'mon!
Oh, that's in!
That's in!
What would you do with €1,000?
What would you spend it on?
My hospital bill
after trying to receive these strokes!
But what if I fake it?
I'm sure he won't see that coming
Oh, you got it wrong this time!
If we fail, it's because of the mic!
Yeah!
That's a good excuse!
Easy money!
Nice! Very good!
Does he serve with the wrong hand?
Oh, nice return!
Wow!
I'm going to go to the end
He doesn't play who fears!
Yep!
OK!
Did I even have a chance?
Probably not!
Oh, we have our next challenger
marching in with confidence!
I've never tried
to return an ATP level serve
So, now I have a chance!
It's going to be pretty hard for you
Or not!
Oh, was it in?
Yeah, clearly in, in my view
140 KPH!
That's a great serve!
Best serve of my whole life!
I'm actually sorry about this
I want to hear the compliments
140 KPH? The serve was pretty fast!
Professional players, they serve
second service like that!
Oh!
Coming!
She tried the double bounce technique
Väinö the tennis dog!
Oh, she got it!
Väinö is celebrating too!
Wooh!
Oh!
If you catch it, you get ten dog biscuits!
Wow!
What will you do with the €1,000?
I need to buy a six month
Dating present for my girlfriend
And also my little sister's
Graduation is coming up
So I need to get something
So let's make this!
I really hope you get it! Yeah!
Here we go!
He got it on!
That's a clean one!
Did you feel any pressure there?
Yes!
100%
I need to guess backhand or forehand
and then I have to go with my gut!
Last challenger of the day
The final dance!
Oh, here we go!
Otto, take it easy!
I'll buy you a coffee if I can make it!
Was it in?
Yeah!
It was good!
Zero chance!
This time the winner is
Otto Virtanen!
Congrats!
Thank you!
€1,000 to Otto!
Nice! Thank you!
Cold cash!
Thanks for Skillshare
for sponsoring this video
and making it possible
Until next time!